[Music]
when I tell people I've been writing a
book against fantasy often they look at
me suspiciously because most of my
friends are liberal and say oh wait is
this some sort of conservative bubble
you attacking liberals and progressives
and it's a natural question to ask
because a lot of people associate
empathy with liberal and progressive
politics and they associate other traits
with with conservatives the
conservatives who say they associate
reason with conservatives the Liberals
would say we associate selfishness and
self-interest with conservatives but one
thing people often agree about is that
on both sides is that the liberals are
more in tactic for better or worse and
if so then my attack on empathy is an
attack on liberal politics and that is
certainly be interesting but that's not
the way I'm going to go I think there's
some experimental evidence that actually
liberals are a little bit more impacted
than conservatives there's empathy tests
that you could give and it turns out
liberal score a little bit higher in
conservatives with libertarians below
everybody kind of on the floor here and
but it's not a big difference and it
turns out when it comes to political
debates
typically the the debate isn't over
whether or not to empathize it's over
who to empathize with do you emphasize
with with black teenagers were shot by
cops are the empathize with cops
who have a difficult and dangerous job
to empathize with with the parents of a
toddler who got shot by a gun due to
lack stemless Rd empathize with somebody
who is raped because she is not
permitted has no right to own the gun to
defend ourselves
she empathize with the woman or the
fetus to empathize with the beneficiary
of affirmative action who otherwise
wouldn't get into a college or was the
white kid who was going to get in
because his grades are great but this
isn't going to get in cuz he's he's
white and so on and so forth for every
every sort of argument were we're
liberals and conservatives face off
against
each side points to somebody to
empathize with and argues that way and I
think this is a horrible way to have
political discussion any policy of any
scope from affirmative action to gun
laws to abortion laws it's going to have
some winners and losers go inevitably
people who suffer upon any application
of law and so pointing out oh let me
tell you the story of somebody who
suffered somebody who suffered because
of Obamacare somebody who suffered
because we're we're getting rid of
Obamacare
it's a stupid argument it's an appeals
to the passions well what you really
want to know is statistics you want to
know well how many people are suffering
how many get were better off this way
and how many people are worse off that
way
now I said for many political debates
it's always a question of who you
empathize with but not for all of them
there's some political positions some
moral and social positions where empathy
just favors one side of the issue but I
think it tends to favor the wrong side
so one of these issues is climate change
a lot of people are concerned about
climate change because they they believe
I think with a lot of evidence that
unchecked it will lead to suffering of
millions rats billions of people but
there's nobody to emphasize with there's
no single person you could point to and
say see that crying child she's crying
because of climate change it doesn't
work that way the argument is
statistical on the other hand if you
would try to respond to climate change
by raising gasoline taxes are doing some
sort of other social intervention then
there will be crying children will be
people who suffer so embassies set
argues for inaction where I think the
right policy would involve some sort of
action a second example is free speech
where embassy I think is always on the
side of the center because if I say
something that offends somebody on the
right on the left if I if I mock some
beloved figure if I if I use some terms
as some group doesn't like people will
suffer
and if you're empathic with their
suffering that'll be a good argument for
shutting me up on the other hand if you
have rigorous laws protect preventing
people from speech hate speech laws
anti-free speech laws it's hard to see
the empathic concern here the arguments
in favor of free speech don't tend to be
empathic arguments they tend to be
arguments based on moral principles like
people should have a right to
communicate those long term utilitarian
benefits like society is better off if
everybody has a voice selfish benefits
of the sort of filing you stay your
stuff that I don't like you'll let me
say my stuff that you don't like but
they aren't empathic arguments and here
again empathy favors one side of the
story which is to shut people up to
sensory people and here again I think
it's a was the wrong side of story
[Music]